في الحرب الاوكرانيه ايضا وتيره القتال
بين الروس والاوكرانيين في الشرق تتباطا
احيانا في منطقه اليتا تشدد وتشتد في
مناطق اخرى تبدو اكثر اهميه بالنسبه
للجانبين وفي تفاصيل التطورات الميدانيه
تشهد منطقه صفاد فوق الواقعه بين ليمان
ولوجاست كمان نتابعنا صراعا كبيرا وصف
بالدموي بين كل من القوات الروسيه
والاوكرانيه مما دفع الجيش الاوكراني الى
حشد مزيد من المقاتلين على هذه الجبهه كما
تشاهدون هنا تقدر بعشرات الالف من اجل
العوده والسيطره على مدن كان قد خسرها في
لوكا تحديدا اما القوات الروسيه فتتقدم في
الشمال الروسي حيث منطقه دنياسك التي تضم
باخمود افيتو ومارينكا التي سحب منها
الجيش الاوكراني تحت ضغط الضربات الروسيه
من المحور الشمالي مشاهدينا ننتقل الى
المحور الجنوبي في دونياسك القريبه من
ماريوبل حيث تشهد هذه المنطقه عمليات كروا
فرق بين القوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه
وتحديدا حول مدينه اوجلدار التي تعتبر
استراتيجيه هنا ومهمه للجانبين وفقا
مسؤولين عسكريين غربيين
[موسيقى]